after dr anthony fauci who earlier in
the pandemic urged
schools to remain closed changed his
position
on the situation kentucky senator rand
paul is now calling on fauci to
apologize
to every single parent and school-age
child in america
spring senator paul member of the health
education labor and pensions committee
he joins us now senator good morning to
you so what is it exactly that you want
to hear from dr fauci
well i think this illustrates the danger
of centralizing power
and decision making in one person or in
washington because when one person is so
wrong
as dr fauci has been it has grave
effects for
millions of school children the evidence
has been clear for six months
evidence from entire countries in europe
and in asia
that schools do not lead to a surge that
kids are poor transmitters of this
countrywide studies were showing this
six months ago and he wouldn't listen
and i tried to convince him of this and
now he sort of flippantly says
oh we're going to let kids go to school
we're just going to close the bars
well we should also look at the evidence
on that do lockdowns
you know prevent the spread of this
right now we have more mandates
and more lockdowns than we've ever had
and yet the incidence of covid is rising
exponentially
it may argue that none of the things we
are doing are working and we at least
ought to be honest
and assess it from an honest perspective
not a biased one
you you you use the words you tried to
convince
dr fauci back in june this is an
exchange
with him on the schools that again were
shut
at that time listen
all of this body of evidence about
schools around the world shows there's
no surge
all of the evidence shows that it's rare
but i hear nothing of that coming from
you
all i hear dr falchi is we can't do this
we can't do that
did you get the sense then that he
wasn't listening that
he had some other reason why he wanted
the schools to remain closed and what
are you suggesting
or can you he make the case that more
data points were needed to come to this
conclusion
or months of studying and observing kids
in the classroom
well you know we went to a two-hour
hearing back in june we've been through
several of these
and not one person brought up from the
so-called experts
that the mortality rate among children
was about one in a million
so i brought this up with dr fauci and
immediately his defensive response was
what about kawasaki's disease well
kawasaki's disease is a
rare rare complication of viral illness
and yes it does exist and it's not to
discount it if your child gets it
but we shouldn't be closing schools
because of it because we get it every
year and it's very very rare
but he wasn't really listening and i
think the reason is is that with dr
fauci
i think his belief that we should submit
that we're
all members of the hive we're all
members of the collective
that submission is more important than
the facts for example in the spring he
said masks don't matter
and don't work new england journal of
medicine also said in an editorial that
they're basically a talisman that they
don't work
outside the hospital setting but then
they change their course over time
but they're not really looking at data
we have mask mandates in dozens and
dozens of states and countries
and every without fail every time we've
instituted a mandate
the actual incidence of the disease has
risen so there's no evidence that these
mandates are working and we're crippling
the economy
so maybe we ought to reassess what we're
doing i think we should also be very
clear here's dr
val fauci in his own words and now
saying the school should be open listen
we say it not being facetiously as a
soundbite or anything but you know
close the bars and keep the schools open
the default position
should be to try as best as possible
within reason
to keep the children in school to get
them back to school
senator also to be clear on where you
stand on this you're saying the students
are safe in the school as long as
they're maintaining social distance
wearing masks and engaging in these
safety protocols correct
i think there are reasonable things you
can do in school
for the small children i wouldn't have
them wearing masks i don't think it
makes any difference
and really we ought to reassess what
we're doing on this trying to take some
precautions is reasonable
but there are now people saying dr fauci
included that when we have a vaccine
you're still going to have to wear a
mask so people do need to push back i'm
one of those who are immune
and i keep pushing back 13 million
americans have had this
we don't need to tell them they have to
wear a mask the thing is is immunity is
working
it's working as well as the vaccine
works and when we get the vaccine
hopefully we can all be free of these
encumbrances senator i've got to leave
it there but are you suggesting there
should be some sort of
accountability when it comes to dr fauci
or
others who are advising that schools be
shut as long as they have
now learning that children really aren't
spreading the disease
well it's the same people who predicted
millions and millions of people would
die from this they've been wrong at
every turn
their models only work when they
continue to adjust them with reality
but they never have been accurate from
the very beginning it turns out that
this is a
a terrible difficult disease for the
elderly
and for the kids this is the truth it
actually is less deadly than the
seasonal flu for children
and we should acknowledge that this is a
disease that is different
depending on your age group and in a
free society everybody should get to be
able to
analyze the data and make their own
decisions senator appreciate your time
this morning i'd like to follow up with
you on all of that soon
thanks thank you